hello I'm a stalk just like [ __ ] Game
of Thrones isn't that yeah you're there
with the sod yes my lord
very good who's that I don't know which
if you're a fan of Game of Thrones oh
yeah July
did you see the trailer yeah it's
intense we should watch it together as a
family with Hugh who with Hugh with who
with Hugh Grant us all of us everyone
ders we don't know anyone that doesn't
watch it
your brother watches said my mom my
sister George I hate [ __ ] I'd do this
do you guys know what guys like this
like viewing part you like we like Game
of Thrones
I don't like fantasy so oh you don't
have an imagination you [ __ ] nut you're
not crazy I don't deal I don't deal with
[ __ ] that say I know I'm not into
fantasy I mean guys that go guys that go
I never saw Star Wars the kid I hate it
I hate sci-fi well you have no
imagination and get the [ __ ] out of my
face
it's cool to see you
hobbits running around chasing rings in
midgets with hairy feet you know that
dingleberry what's his name
dingleberry here [ __ ] dingleberry
[Music]
well I mean you're gonna Caston that's
alright guys I mean I you know what
we've been editing [ __ ] because even
last week we added it oh you've been
giving me a heart attack every week for
some reason when we when we take the
time to say hey Bobby don't say these
words it's almost as if you take that as
I'm absolutely gonna say those words I
never like people tell me what to do
listen if you're my friend
call me ching chong I bring a lot of
Ching chongs at your show I tell you
something that might piss you off then I
just wanna say this is for a second let
me just get my point across Andrew Dice
Clay for seven years
literally called me Ching when he would
bring me up on stage he wouldn't even
say my name he go Ching and the one day
I walked up to him I was angry I could
Andrew I know you're a legend and
everything my name is Bobby
don't call me Ching know with I Ching
that you stole own that looks too low ya
know what's not dice
yeah how do you do it dice so you know
what die said to me hey it's not racial
like what is it it's inching your money
since she justified a good you can call
me Ching from now on the other night he
called me Bobby for the first time Wow
growth real grown transformation Bobby
now go wow I got through the ching part
but you can say things like [ __ ] if
you're a friend to me alright okay if I
was a dwarf or a little person call me
[ __ ] or a Faberge egg Faberge eggs a
good one I don't know all these terms
anyway it's fine I don't edit uh you
know what you're right I should went
into a rage you did no no no you don't
know why but I'm just gonna say you do
got mad at me because I stalk it's all
because of this stupid ABC show and you
think there's somebody's gonna you think
somebody's gonna blackmail me I just I
just get weird about you know like crazy
people you get crazy emails all the time
like it's I'm sorry Peter Dinklage oh
what a huge finger so talented I
shouldn't have said those things sorry
Peter Dinklage to all the little people
yes sorry I'm sorry too Elijah Wood yeah
is he little he sure was about your
height he's my I met him once
yes you really yeah he was at the Comedy
Store and I walked by him and he stood
up and he shook my hand and and I also
he said it's a couple of sketches with
Dominic Monaghan
[ __ ] no two hobbits bro damn that's
where I am in life Wow I know too
[Music]